ich hab gedacht ich ganz alleine wochen
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge ist leider ein paar
13 mit c ronnie kai hallo wer war
letztmals dabei stimulieren dass wir
immer noch diese bald farben hier
weitermache und er gerade eine
grasfläche macht weil ich logischerweise
das ganze gerade verbessert habe im
griff konnte mir so was von der sache
gar nicht sorry so also brauchen auf
jeden fall sieht kann er hat leute die
trinken ein bisschen die leute direkt
ein bisschen mehr
es gibt leute die laufende richtig rein
und gemacht conny jetzt noch den kopf
neben konjunktur macht das ist meine
farben die mühe für die möchte ich
kontrolle haben
das schafft wiederum gemacht dass man es
nicht mindestens drei viertel willst
mich verarschen
ja ja womit ngn
nein na ja wir brauchen ja auch noch
verändert wir brauchen noch open flasche
oder gar nicht brauchen ist folgendes
also meine jobs grußwort und bosch wird
ich glaube dass du machst die quest
gerade ach so ja die habe ich auch
gemacht
oh ja gut im bett wird
das einkommen bis hässlich diesmal nicht
helfen wirklich lange wollen die stillen
geflogen die jetzt weg
natürlich getroffen nein auch mann der
wichtigsten opfer
und darum geht wo sein alter vieler
skelette drin man bekommt nicht genug
weil junge was hinter viele skelette
alter walhall besetzt ich geh jetzt mal
zum hörer bildes zu gucken was er denn
so hat er's brigitte häberli blume liegt
schnee wenn wir den kakao boden gehen
junge ich habe sich das vorgebracht
danke ads da war ich aber gar nicht hin
doch auch ich heiße mal wir müssen
irgendwie erst wenn die argumentation
scrubs doch das gras sondern ein
bisschen weiter wächst am tag ist die
luft rein gewachsen oder hast du dir
setzt durch blumen will und wie kann das
gras gewachsen
das ist folge kribbelt es ist verhindert
dass gerade das rennen gehen warum
sendermann der ändern denn was im ändern
einfach den neuen sachen mitzunehmen
brauchen den stelle ich will dein
theater aus spaß hast du dich schon
wieder meine farm
geron ich was meine farm ok farm ist
fertig also wir brauchen jetzt hat jetzt
kommt von eigentlich behalten ja da
hinten fehlt unseren klotz aber
letztlich egal
madame pompadour bank am wochenende man
ja ich weiß du brauchst beide 1
warum oder sind cdu ist voll gewachsen
hierbei wenn wir einen haben wir es
machen und zwar ja ich habe ja jetzt mit
dem was ich meine
hier sind zwei mal ab und sagt was du
raus kriegst
alt aber die kommen sagen warum wissen
menschen haben mehr sahen
das ist schlimm müssen solche kleinen
wege rübermachen zweier heizen waren 11
15 kreuzen dann könnt ihr eine fette
module erfüllen weil der trainer hatte
eine weißt du was gehört dass hunger der
welt brot ist nur einen typ deine aus
dem haus da der eine von den halt hast
du noch eins dieser komischen dschungel
holz dieser komischen dschungel holz
dinge blöcke
dschungel holzblöcke das macht sinn mehr
habe ich nicht deswegen dass er voll
doof wie viel kakao bauern hast du 9
kann man irgendwie nicht
und wir können ja noch leisten wir
müssen jetzt erst mal ich will dass
diese form schon jetzt müssen wir warten
die farbe ist das eigentlich nur 22 das
sind hässlich hässlich wir brauchen
diese übergänge reisen spitzenleute rauf
und dann wird auch
machst du hier
cool aus fehlt noch ein bisschen die
beleuchtung banal und da fehlt ein
bisschen volumen mit der farm volumen
ein bisschen fehlt ein bisschen licht
waren jetzt damit du hier die ganze zeit
meine kakaobohnen das habe ich mir
erarbeitet guck mal ich habe mir das
erarbeitet
da habe gegenwärtig getötet assmann
ein fall für die verbraucher
riskant machen
muss erst mal gern mal ein
bis zu wenig
lasst uns doch mal
eine ganz frühe form der ruiniert
wenn jetzt alles für gesetz weg stimmt
alles denken meine farm
du willst du dass ich die töte gegen
sagen nee nee ich hab noch was war das
leben 18 habe ich jetzt ja gut dann
tauscht ein bisschen ein
ich weiß nicht mehr gehen war ein
ereignis kommt raus die samenspende also
ich brauche 64 kakaobohnen zu 64 kekse
ballaballa ich finde noch ein game watch
und ich mache erst mal alles kaputt
wieso kann das eigentlich ein server für
die übelste es nicht mehr als ändern wir
ein server 14
jetzt bleiben aber steht sie mich jetzt
abgewartet werde ich mal um deine farm
jetzt hier sammeln knochenmehl und das
ist das meiner erfahrung eigentlich wäre
das alles nicht schon richtig ich meine
so ist das schlechte meine fans andere
weine stammen ist zu viel gemacht wie du
jetzt im diesmal am 1 bei der hier ja
auch kein dürfen alter das habe ich
alles gemacht man
ich bin dir nachgeschaut ob die
produktivität wenn du das weiß man
wachsen würde wisst ihr ich ging ja
deswegen hab ich ja gesagt hol ich noch
nie gemacht kambodscha erwarten so 44
kaká habe ich mittlerweile kann man ja
nicht einfach so rum laufen da wächst
mittlerweile immerhin gerne eine bohne
beim poker conny wir können ein bisschen
gute machen 15 ok was können wir erst
mal beenden die nächste farm nächste
ding es hier schaffen ist spross virtual
world deutschland haben ihr angebot auf
ihn nochmal vier hast nach meerholz
ich hab gar nichts ich ja wirklich
sicher wäre das war ein stellen warum
ich nur drei dings habe also ich habe
jetzt 62 kakaobohnen das heißt noch hast
du keinen letzlinger total rote woche
noch zwei mal kein festival gut raus
bekommen sagte bruce wird brauchen wir
auch oder
noch nämlich nicht mehr nur noch von gut
das heißt ich erstmal erfahrung ist ja
klar würde ich habe egal ob ich jetzt
mache ich nicht machen
hier könnte welche schenken nicht carbon
jungle world also das wird heute okay
ich war noch ein setzling hinten
vielleicht ja ich schaue mal ganz kurz
was ich mit kakaobohnen noch quellen
kann übrigens machen wir erstmal hat
wenn es euch gefallen hat dürfte einen
daumen hoch geben weiterhin tipps oder
irgendwas in kommentare schreiben und es
passiert ist dann bei evonik zschau